豊臣秀行 天下一のぶっ飛びマシーン 千葉県出身
織田慎太郎 セオリー無視の一発屋 千葉県出身
徳川康兵衛 麻雀理論を全く持たない タコなき男 千葉県出身
明智光一 超合理的理論麻雀を打つ 試合校舎 千葉県出身
はやりあきな、一応トヨテミの恋人、驚異的な月の文字主、千葉県出身
リーチ
来たな
なるほど
おめえいつからそんなパイ切るようになったんだ
リーチに現物を切ってるようじゃダメなのさ
一点に読んで強いパイを切る
そうすりゃ自然に感性が冴えて
パイが見えてくる
ルッ!通しだ!
ウラッ!
通し!
フリフリ!
どうした、どうした?
通すんだ!
一体、全体、お前、どんな手作ってんだよ!
そのうち、リーチをかけてる方が受け身になっちまう。
こいつは、最高に気持ちがいいぜ!
スルッ!
ア゙ァー
お、おめえ
ハイテイでそんなもんを
え?
ハイテイだったの?
あ
タイヤを飲み
ローン
ドタカメ
リーチー
ハイテイ
ウラオマテ
うがあああああああ
わあああああ
夢か
はい、豊臣ですが
あ、豊臣くん、私早見です
秋名ちゃん?
実は今日私の誕生日なの
え、そうなの?
だから今日私の家に来ない?
二人だけでお祝いしましょう
やっほー
私お料理とか細かいものは色々用意しとくから
トヨタミ君はケーキだけ買ってきてね
いらっしゃいませ
このデコレーションケーキください
誰かのお誕生日ですか
そう
彼女ですか
アキナって入れてくれる
憎いね、この…って書いちゃおうか。
え?え?
ありがとうございました。
彼女のお誕生日ですか?
もうやだな。もう何度も同じこと…
え?
奇遇だな。こんなとこでおめえと会うなんてよ。
それに見えるはケーキでね、だか。
こ、これは…
どれ、せっかくだから俺たちでケーキを届けてやろうぜ。
ああ、そのケーキはダメ!
心配することねえ、ダン。
おめえも一緒に行くだ
ほらほらサクサク行くだ
よくこんなケーキ買う金あったよな
俺たちへの借金の返済は一体どうなったのかな
パプパプ
パプパプじゃねえよ借金少しでも返してもらうぜ
なんだよこんなケーキなんか
お願いだだからそのケーキだけは
はっ!勝つことだ。
俺たちに勝ってこのケーキを取り戻せ。
ツモ!チョン!メンホン!
ツモ!
単品ドラドラ!
リーズも三眼光!
ああ、楽しい麻雀だな。
なら、なら。
あ?
おめえはなんでいつもそんな嫌な顔してんだ
しらけるじゃねえか
ロンピンフドライチー親で肉
絶対に勝つ
勝ってアキナちゃんと二人だけのハッピーバースデーを過ごすんだ
チー
ポン
なんだ
ああ、あの泣きとあの捨て範囲。初は場に二枚切れてるし、想像の一通か一二三の三色しかねえじゃねえか。
ったく、成長しないやつだ。
ジョン!三色同行のみ!ニックよろしく!
-なに?!-なに?!
トヨトミが連チャルした!
-なんてこった!-なんてこった!
お、おら、初めて見たな!
ジョン!タイヤをのみ!
その順
トヨタミの連チャンを初めて見た3人は動揺を隠しきれないでいた
トヨタミはこまめに上がり続けた
そして
オーラスで2位との差は1万5千点
ダントツのぶっちぎりだ
よしドラアンこったぞ
リーチ
だ、オラもリーチだ
オシ、オラのテンパったぜ
3色を狙うなら、ナンギリのペンチャンチーソーを待ち
だがチーソーはトヨトミからは出ない
シンタロウのリーチ危ないからな
トヨトミから出るとすれば、パーソーのワンチャンスで、むしろここは、急走短期!
同順3人リーチか。くそー、来い!
来た!サプローQ1でマグンチュンドラさん!スチーワンならそれにサンアーコーがついて羽目!
ステハイからいって、急走は90%以上通る!
親に振らない限り、逆転はない!
勝った!これで勝った!
明菜ちゃん、今すぐ行くからね!
おめでとう、明菜ちゃん!
ありがとう、豊臣くん。
おいしい、このシチュー。このサイドもすっごいうまい。
どうしたの?アキナちゃん。
なんだか、あたしじゃなくて、トヨタミ君のお祝いみたい。
でも、よかった、来てくれて。
ローン
ビーチ一発
何ドライチ
一万二千
ビーチ一発
ビーフ一通
八千と来たもんだ
お互いいい読みだぜな
まったく
ご同系のおいたり
あれトリプルローンありだったよな
何でもありだ
悪い、悪い。俺もロンだ。
リーチ一発、コンロをチートイ、ウラウラ。一万六千。
ス、スーパーズガーン。
スーパーショーン
頼む もう半チャンスだからそのケーキ
そういやトヨタミ いいジャケット着てるじゃねえか
おいトヨタミ 小銭落ちたぞ
ケーキごちそうさ いいもん手に入れたな
まあまあ
遅いな豊臣くん
せめて、せめてこのカップラーメンをゆっくり食べ終えてから出かけたなら
あの三人組に会うこともなかったかもしれない
しかし、あの電話の直後の彼にとって
129円のこのカップラーメンがどれほどの意味を持っていたというのか
プロは相手の革なんか読まない
それよりも相手が今何を考えているのか
こいつを読むのさ
こいつはあと30秒でお茶を飲むなとか
それが29秒でも31秒でもいけない
30秒で飲むのをピタリ当てるんだ
ヤスはあと7秒で煙草に火をつける
1、2、3、4、5、6、7
当たった!
そうだよ!当たりだよ!
リーチ三眼光ドライチ!
ほらほら、早く展望をよこせ!
釣りはいらん!
あら、ソフトバラ!
洗面器…
そうだ、洗面器だ!
おっと、またリーチ。
こりゃ。
なんだべ。
現物、硬い。
マージャンなんて、4人が洗面器に顔を突っ込んでいるようなもんさ。先に顔を上げたほうが負けなのさ。
テンパッタ!カウン1!
ポン!
さあ、あげちまいな!
いい加減、顔を!
顔をあげちまいな!
ツモ!
レンゴンインペイコー!
なんのツモ!
本郎ちとい!
ツモ!ツワンコー!
スーパー…
アキラちゃん
おはようトヨタミックン
遅くなってごめん
嫌な夢を見たりしたもんだから
いやいやなんでもないさあ行こう
あきなちゃんといつかきっと何が何しますように
豊臣くんが麻雀をやめてくれますように
ねえおみくじ引きましょう
うん
あたし6番
僕12番
きゃー大吉
ねえ豊臣くんは
もう一枚引いてみたら
もう一枚
お客さんもうやめたら
ギブミーラストチャンス
やったー
全部で5000円いただきます
でも5000円もかけてとうとう小吉一枚引いたんだからよかったじゃない
私豊臣くんの粘り強さに感動したわ
あらほらあそこで滝技能を奉納してるわ
どうしたの、豊臣くん。そんなに怯えて。
豊臣くん!
嫌な夢見たからな
おー豊臣
いやーこんなとこで会えるなんて
気づくんですかこういうの
今週は3人で温泉行ってるんじゃなかったの
言った確かに言った
だがお前の顔見たくなってな
途中で帰ってきたんだよ
豊臣に選別もらわなきゃ、土産も買えねえべ。
ちょっと袋小さかったべか、これじゃ。
やっす。お前は黙ってろって。
でも、まあ、そういうことだ。
ほんじゃ、温泉まんじゅう目指して、最初のはんちゃん、いってみようか。
あ、黒子無双、難短期でテンパっちまった
場には難が一枚
えい、リーチだ
なんだ?
シンタロウは一発ツムがあっかな
ないとくべ
こいつ
ほら引っ掛けするなよ
僕もリーチかけときゃよかったな
あの小袖当たれたのに役がないから当たれない
ドラもあるのに
つもれ
通せ
出た
100万コクシムソ
ローン5200
つか
なんだ今トヨタミがつも切りしたんだ
オラが泣かなきゃつもってたでねえか
長っこでシンタロウは上がれなかっただ
スカンポ
オラはなんてついてねえだ
ミスミス言い反応がしただ
オラはもう一生温泉まんじゅうがあくえねえだ
ママこんなこともあるってん
あたしトヨタミ君の粘り強さに感動したわ
そ、そうだ
大凶を何度引こうが最後には正気地を引いてやる
これからの男は粘り強さだ
粘って粘って
糸引くくらいの粘り腰で勝負だ
見ててね、アキラちゃん
はった
スーアンコウテンパイ
チュンで待つか
チュンは地獄町だが山に入ってたらそれまでだ
イーピンはあんこにしてない限り出る
しかしチュンキリイーピン町ではイーピン三品の変則町
しかも三品ではただの三あんこの町もできてしまう
この手を三あんこで上がるわけにはいかない
ええいママよ二つが同順に出ることはまずないはず
イーピン短期で待つ
三品
同順にいいピン出るなよ
こいつはいらねえな
なんだこんなもん
あら
マージャンなんて
4人が洗面器の中に顔を突っ込んでいるようなもんさ
先に顔を上げた方が負けなのさ
そ、そうだ朝見た夢だ
先に洗面器から顔を上げた奴が負ける
そして僕は負けるわけにはいかない
ズガーン
びっくりしたなあもう
2曲続けてコクシムソーター
いやーなんか今日すごいついてるなあ
スーパー
ズッゴーン!
俺、4万3千点。
俺は3万2千点だ。
俺は8万点。しっかりつけとけよ。
ズガーン!
アキナちゃん!
私を置いてきぼりにして、また麻雀やってたのね。もう知らない!
こ、これには深いわけ…
秋日より空に浮かんだはぐれ雲
春がこのうち夏が来ていつの間にやら秋ふかし
豊臣の春は一体いつになったらやってくるのか
一句赤とんぼどこへ行くのか青天井
明日があるさ負けるな豊臣
がんばれ豊臣
トヨタミ君を完璧なマージャンマシーンに改造すれば
あの3人に勝てるかもしれない
昔のトヨタミ君に戻ってくれるかも
次回スーパーズガン
恐怖のトヨタミマシーンとスノーサイドズガン
きっと見てね
眠っちゃいや
お疲れ様でした
ご視聴ありがとうございました
ここは三面町どころ
行くぞカンちゃん
福島そこの席が肌
スーパーリーフォーマー
天空にやりぬいて
勝手飲み干すビールがうまい
スカッと
お酒はいどちがけ
ご視聴ありがとうございました